hasina begum has a few light moments
with her family as they scrape by with
basic supplies in this relief camp
they left their village when it was
flooded and now share a room with 20
people
she says they had to wait four days
before being given some food they left
all their belongings at home and don't
know when they can return
we go through the same thing every one
or two years we lose all our belongings
we have to work hard again and rebuild
everything only to lose them again to
floods this is our life
heavy rains continue to lash assam state
impacting half a million people
many have left some waded through rising
waters others use rafts floods have
devastated hundreds of villages the
brahmaputra is one of the longest rivers
in the world and main source of water
for this region it often floods during
monsoon what's concerning is that the
rains have come early and are more
intense for this time of year in many
parts of the state this river is flowing
above danger levels
rescue efforts are underway at least 50
000 people are in relief camps while
military helicopters are dropping basic
supplies for the thousands still
stranded landslides have blocked major
roads and rail links cutting off some of
the worst hit areas in southern assam
[Music]
the water level keeps rising every day
the people here are in difficult
situation there are concerns about food
water and shelter we are not getting the
kind of relief that is needed
weather forecasters expect heavy rains
to continue over the next few days
causing more damage and challenging
rescue efforts pavni mithal al-jazeera
guhati in northeast india